simply say writing in how many social
media venues would you suggest an
entrepreneur engage in especially as
companies like Facebook periscope
meerkat blob and so on make their entry
into the market it's a great question we
hear that one a lot so I think for
social media you know there's so many
great platforms that you can use but it
can get overwhelming really really fast
and I definitely don't think that
entrepreneurs or anybody should feel
obligated to be on every platform that
is in existence because that it's that's
just unmanageable basically at the end
of the day um so just kind of pick one
or two to kind of get started you know
Facebook Twitter Linkedin start with the
big ones YouTube to kind of just get
familiar with you know talking to a
social audience and just getting a sense
for each platform maybe even just
getting started with one or two to
really if you're really just getting
started um and just get more familiar
with you know whether or not that
platform is even right for your business
because like Evan said you know there
are certain things that you know video
might be better for your business and
blogging might be better Twitter might
be better it really might take some time
for you to test out different platforms
see what works see if you're getting the
engagement that you want see if people
are asking the right questions if
they're interacting with you if they're
going back to your website you know
really take some time to to sort through
each one and then make a decision at the
end of the day if to see if it's really
right for you I know it can we support
stressful as an entrepreneur because we
have all these things we have to run in
our business already now you know I just
figured out facebook now we need to know
meerkat and periscope and blab and
snapchat and it can just seem
overwhelming that a new thing opens up
and now you have to learn it um I think
marketing 101 is you want to be where
your customers are if your customers are
on this platform in a big number then
that's where you want to be I thought
Twitter was stupid at the start when I
first got on to what people we're
talking about their cats and with a for
lunch and like I don't have time for
this i'm running my business i don't i
don't need to share what i mean for
lunch good for you guys that it's not
for me but i got
my name anyway because you want to make
sure nobody kind of takes your name and
squats on it and does something with it
then I just did a search and I found
that people were talking about me and
talking about my website on Twitter and
I wasn't a part of the conversation
which is not good right like even if
you're not going to be active in the
platform you want to at least recognize
your champions you want to thank them
you want to you know say show some
appreciation them so they're going to do
it again on going because that's that's
going to encourage him to want to keep
doing it and so step one is figuring out
are my customers here what's the
demographic does it line up with who I'm
trying to sell to and if it does then
you should consider look around if it
doesn't don't worry about it you know
snapchat excuse really young are you
selling two teenagers are you selling to
senior citizens right figure out where
you want to be I would overlay that with
what are you really good at and where is
your passion right so if you are great
on camera like we talked about are great
at writing you can leverage those
talents and those skills and that
passion to create amazing content so
YouTube was my favorite platform because
a lot of entrepreneurs you guys are all
on YouTube and I love being on camera as
opposed to other forms of writing or
doing interviews and speaking and so
that matches up best for me and I'm on
the other platforms but I'm most engaged
on YouTube and so if you can combine
those things where's your audience and
what are you good at you want to learn
more about where were that intersects
that's we should be